BBC has announced the new doctor the
13th software mr. C's doctor is taking
the form of Jodie Whittaker who is a
fantastic actor I am so excited about
this for the last fifty three years the
Doctor Who I mean you would say he's an
imaginary Eileen with a magic
screwdriver has taken the form of a male
human but now and there's you see you
got the whole list right here
can everyone daily well you got Hartnell
trout and pertwee Tom Baker Peter
Davison Colin Baker semester McCoy Paul
McGann Chris Eccleston David Tennant
Matt Smith Peter Capaldi there but now
that's imaginary alien with a magic
screwdriver is a female some actual male
humans who've never screwed anything our
screaming political correctness run amok
at their computers which then drives
into little spots that they will never
wipe off nor will anyone else for that
matter they will die alone this is a lot
of dudes and this doesn't even count the
war doctor so that's another one another
one so to say that the doctor has to be
male means you're not actually a fan of
the show cuz Time Lords can regenerate
into anything so if you're following the
actual lore of the show it is 100%
appropriate
sinners are not Stephanie Rhonda good if
I taking people's angry comments and
turning them into episode titles like
this episode nobody wants a TARDIS full
of brog or or this this little gem tag
travel is for men and men hopefully also
urinals men and men only so if you're
not going to watch the show because of
this and you're going to stomp your feet
and slam your door against your keyboard
seriously legitimately doctor who skin
cares community question why don't these
guys want women to time-travel Andy
they're afraid they'll go back in time
and cook themselves yes I'll run there
now instead of boning football players
chicks are going to go back in time and
James cape oh yeah point Jenny they're
afraid they're going to remake the
original Ghostbusters with girls Oh
[Applause]